this
is another perfect example of why I only use the term anti choice
because pro life is simply not an accurate term to describe this policy position
when read as six anti choice justices and Missouri is an anti choice state
you can reconcile the clear contradiction
widely available research demonstrates that abortion bans
actually have disastrous effects
on the lives of both mothers and their children
so um
after the Roe v Wade decision came out
we saw a whopping 30 to 40% decrease in the maternal mortality rate
of people of color in the postro era
researchers are continuing to gather data on the effects of various states
abortion bans but
researchers are estimating an increase in maternal mortality between 21 and 38%
not only do abortion bands increase the maternal mortality rate
they also increase the infant mortality rate
research is still being developed
on the connection between increased infant mortality rates
and abortion bands but one logical hypothesis is that
when women tell you they do not have the capacity to care for a new child
that it may be wise to listen to them also lines up with research
um I'm reading from the turnaway study
that shows that when a woman is denied a wanted abortion
that child over the next four years is more likely to live in poverty
to live in a household that is dependent on public assistance
and to live with adults who don't
who do not have enough money to pay for food
housing and transportation
and those are literally just two examples
if you wanna know more about the disastrous consequences
on actual people's lives of abortion bans
I can't recommend the turnaway study enough
it is a ten year study
on the consequences of denying individuals a wanted abortion
I'm the feminist lawyer drop any questions you might have in the comments
and I'll do my best to be helpful